here with reaction she is the co-host of
the top hit show the five judge uh
janine pirro is with us along with fox
news contributor tammy bruce judge let's
start with you only from the legal
aspect of this like i would not doubt i
i can't give specifics but i'm pretty
confident that new york state the only
reason that wall street companies remain
is because they probably get benefits
tax benefits
let's say favors that people like
we would never get
uh
for disney to have these these special
uh you know rights for since 1967 i say
okay time to go why shouldn't they be
treated equally well they should be
treated equally and the truth is these
per this permit that has existed since
1967 can be revoked by the governor and
you know then disney will not have all
of those rights that you
articulated but you know you have to ask
yourself the fundamental question here
who the heck are these corporate
executives from disney to criticize a
law that was that was voted on by the
legislature in florida signed by the
governor and you know supported by more
than 50 percent of the democrats in
florida and the majority of floridians
who is this small majority of woke
people who decide that they're going to
dictate what we're gonna do and i love
that ron desantis doesn't buckle down to
their nonsense and i love that what he's
saying is he's standing there at that
podium and he's saying don't mess with
us because we can mess with you and we
can mess with you legitimately we don't
have to make up a narrative now let me
tell you something sean i have two kids
and if anybody anybody tried to talk to
my five-year-old or six-year-old about
whether or not they really wanted to be
a boy or a girl or sexual orientation
the first thing i would do is i would
call the police there should be no
teacher talking to my kid about sex and
i would then call child protective
services to talk about teachers and wear
influence over our children none of them
should be discussing this with our kids
now we've got parents who have the right
to protect and know what's going on in
school and finally joe biden's got a his
administration is imploding as you said
at the beginning of your opening he now
wants to make sure he stays on top of
the florida law to make sure that
they're monitoring it so children's
civil rights are not being violated that
guy there
and he supports funding surgery for
minors so that they can change sexes and
he's talking about the bottom surgeries
and bottom line here is this
nobody says you can't say gay and and
wanda sykes and the rest of them ought
to read the bill before they open their
traps and go gay gay gay gay gay and
that's right
and and tammy if that doesn't celebrate
i'm done that's it um very funny so
we watched glenn young in commonwealth
of virginia these education issues and
parental involvement in schools was a
very key issue that i believe factored
into him winning the state a purple
state like like the commonwealth of
virginia
when you look at this law and you look
at the reaction to all of this
and
it's only for k through
third grade and i would like schools to
focus on reading writing math science
and computers because we pay more per
capita than any other country and we
have the worst results
is that unreasonable to have parental
involvement and and maybe those are
issues they can deal with in after
school programs and parents are
uncomfortable talking to their kids
about these kinds of issues and they can
opt in rather than opt out
well you crazy wild guy sean hannity
that parents should have
control over their children be their
moral arbiters that they're they're the
natural and legal moral arbiters of
their children they they are the people
who obviously have a legal right to
control the lives of those of toddlers
uh their little children of their family
the reality is you're right these are uh
marginal extremists the judge is right
as well regarding this is a small
minority of people they are extremists
they've been placed in particularly
influential positions they are the
loudest voices in the room they are
bullies
they're bullying everyone else chapic
and everybody else who's at that top
are afraid they have a knee-jerk
reaction nobody read the bill and they
don't think about they're in a bubble
shot they don't think about not just
virginia but my goodness san francisco
and the recall of three school board
members for exactly the same reason woke
policies changing school names critical
race theory uh
you know sexual instruction woke-ism for
young ages when it comes to
homosexuality sexual identity little
kids i've said it before i'll say it
again there are no straight uh children
there are no gay children there's just
children they are beyond that and
ultimately and this is well put by
someone on twitter
that this is about this is a horrible
dynamic and a heartbreaking dynamic of
adults destroying the innocence of
childhood to validate themselves
this is why every parent every american
must stand up against it it's like keep
politics out of football keep politics
out of disney let kids enjoy their
childhood let kids you know let's open
up kids
yeah all right good to see you both
thank you on this friday night hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else